a Jo Christian values lie at the heart
and soul of Western civilization itself
and they lie at the heart and soul of a
lot of the Enlightenment values that we
ourselves tend to value as as even
secular people now the very basis of the
notion that human beings have intrinsic
worth and intrinsic quality that is a a
notion that cannot be discovered from
science it's not something that you can
pick up just by looking at a science
textbook after all we're just an
agglomeration of cells and the glommer a
ssin of various firing synapses the idea
that human beings have inherent value
that's something that springs from the
judeo-christian tradition the idea and
we're all equal before God we have all
equal rights before God that again it
comes from the ideas in Genesis the idea
that as human beings we are created as
individuals made in the likeness of God
and therefore we have to value the
rights of other human beings the moral
structures of the Ten Commandments these
are all the things that provide the
grounding for a social fabric that
allows for freedom to flourish now then
a lot of people who attacked your day'll
Christian values because they believe
that judeo-christian values is too
exclusive that the judeo-christian
values is rooted in faith as opposed to
in logic but the reality of the
situation is that everybody's moral
framework is rooted in certain
assumption the question of how we are to
live a moral life is rife with questions
about how we ought to view human beings
in their place in the world if you
believe in the sort of scientific
materialist worldview that says that
human beings are basically just material
wandering through space with the
illusion of free will it's very
difficult to make a moral case for why
you should act in a certain way why you
should act as though you have free will
why should act in in the interests of
others as opposed to in your own
interest if however you believe that
there is a moral standard that stands
above and beyond you but you were
created with a soul something that
exists beyond death if you believe in
judeo-christian values in other words
that provides the logical framework that
allows for the flourishing of human
freedom that doesn't mean that every
religion based society is going to end
in human freedom very often religion
just like any other force in human
history can be used for tyranny and
you've seen that to people who want to
cram down particular doctrines people
who believe in a theocracy where
religious authorities get to declare
what you can and cannot do but the
true purpose of judeo-christian values
is to determine your place in a in a
universe that is governed by rules that
is discernible by human reason human
intellect and this is this is rife in
judeo-christian theology ranging from
Maimonides and in Judaism to Aquinas in
Catholicism to the great Protestant
theologians as well the fact of the
matter remains that if you want to have
a free country you have to have a social
fabric that is supported by these moral
ideas this is why the French Revolution
was a failure because the French
Revolution tried to create a secular
morality without the framework of
judeo-christian morals and it turns out
that it is very easy to discard the
individual in that map it's incredibly
easy to say the individual doesn't
matter as much as the collective this
was the logic that was used by Rhodes
fier and by the way by Karl Marx it is
easy to say that an alternative moral
system in which individuals don't matter
as much as the sort of collective will
that individuals ought to be grounds
dust and you saw this under communism
you saw this under fascism and the
values that you believed in the values
of free markets the values of free
exchange and free speech and free
thought the value being treated as an
individual again that is rooted in the
belief that you were made as an
individual by God in God's image
and those values have to be promulgated
and responsibility has to be added to
those values because individualism
without any sort of teaching in your
moral debt owed to others ends with
hedonism and it ends with narcissism and
it ends with societal collapse and
anarchy so if you want that balance
between responsibility and freedom if
you want the balance between virtue and
liberty you need judeo-christian values
one of the saddest things that we've
seen in modern society is people
rebelling against churches people saying
the church is bad people actively
fighting against church suggesting the
church is the great oppressor and that
as soon as we get rid of church that
things will will move in a far better
direction that is obviously untrue a lot
of the collapse and meaning that's taken
place in American life a lot of the
violence that we see in our streets a
lot of the suffering that we see is
directly implicated in the destruction
of churches in the destruction of
synagogues in the destruction of
organized religion in which so many
people found community faith in their
neighbors I believe that the people who
lived around them are good and decent
human beings and thus deserving of the
same freedoms that they themselves were
worthy of if you want an overarching
government structure cramming down one
rule from above all you have to do is
dissolve the social fabric that is
rooted in judeo-christian values already
coming up you're gonna hear me talk
about the
issues and many more with the late ravi
zacharias as well as as well as michael
shermer as well as William Lane Craig I
really hope that you enjoy the episode
of the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special
but first if you've been waiting to get
life insurance what exactly are you
waiting for at this point with
everything going on right now a lot of
people are even asking if it's possible
to buy life insurance the answer yes you
can indeed buy life insurance and you
should if you have loved ones depending
on your income you need to as an
insurance marketplace policy genius is
in contact with the life insurance
companies on their platform every single
day they're keeping track of all the
changes in the market so you don't have
to which means then get you covered
quickly and for the best price here's
how it works
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies all in one
place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price this doesn't just
save a lot of legwork you could say 1500
bucks or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they will be there
to take care of everything if you're one
of the many people looking to buy life
insurance right now or auto insurance or
disability insurance you need to head on
over to policy genius com policy genius
will help you find the best rate and
handle the process soup-to-nuts will get
you and your family protected policy
genius.com
this week on the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday's special we've moved into the
summer off-season
and we're bringing you our best moments
from the last two years of shows we'll
listen to guests from my show and hear
their unique perspectives surrounding a
topic and I'll also be sharing some
reflections on each of the guests and
their episodes in this episode we're
focusing on the judeo-christian values
that Western civilization has been built
on and the dialogue I've had with guests
about these values it feels natural to
begin with man I'd also like to take a
moment to honor and remember Ravi
Zacharias
Ravi recently passed away after a fight
against cancer I had the absolute
pleasure of speaking with him about a
year ago in episode 60 Ravi was a
Christian teacher with a 48 year long
career preaching in over 70 countries
offering over 30 books in which he
argued for the existence of God and the
case for Christianity by connecting
faith with reason and focusing on
logical case for theism his ministry's
motto is helping the thinker believe
helping the believer think his latest
book is seeing Jesus from the east a
fresh look at history's most influential
figure which was released since we've
talked Rabi touched the lives of
millions of people his memory will not
soon be forgotten as the work of Ravi
Zacharias international men
streets continues on I would have loved
to talk many more hours about religion
philosophy and God with Robbie but I do
feel a deep gratitude to have had the
privilege to meet and connect with him
through this show it was really
fantastic to talk to Robbie he was one
of the most requested people around the
office people around the office just
loved his work this is also one of the
most popular episodes one of the most
requested what a charming and delightful
and urbane and humane individual Ravi
Zacharias was in our interview listen to
Ravi distinguish the judeo-christian
worldview from all other worldviews one
of the issues that then now comes up
routinely and you know I start with my
book I know that you've experienced it
as well as if you mentioned
judeo-christian civilization if you
mentioned Western civilization there's a
whole school of thought out there now
that this is effectively just a form of
racism that this is a form of white
supremacy which comes I think is an
ironic accusation toward both you and
and toward me but that that attempt to
paint the even the term judeo-christian
civilization is inherently exclusive do
you think that that is it reflects any
accuracy in other words what
distinguishes the judeo-christian
worldview from some of the other
religious worldviews you mentioned early
on that when you have debates with folks
or discussions with folks who are of
other monotheistic faith that those tend
to be some of the hardest conversations
where do you think that the
judeo-christian worldview diverges from
some of the other faiths with which
you've discussed you know I think we're
also paying the penalty of our flaws
historically the church has made huge
blunders you point out some of this in
your book as well how do we hide from
that what it really showed and even the
way they handled side effect progress at
times which is not well done it actually
ends up proving the depravity of it
doesn't prove which is says what the
Bible actually teaches but it proves
what we become as human beings when we
are when we give to ourselves power over
everybody else so I say we have to own
up our mistakes but we have no more
mistakes made than those who are over
counter perspective which are the two
most rogue regimes
the world today if you go back to the
20th century more people were killed in
communist countries than any Democratic
couple a capitalistic system put
together and you know that well you put
the slaughter of people between china
and russia alone and then you bring in
vietnam and cambodia i was in vietnam in
the seventies not as a fighter but as a
working with the chaplains i was only in
my 20s I saw what was happening I was in
Vietnam a few weeks ago and they
themselves talk about what is being done
to them under this heavily atheistic
regime the fact of the matter is to
point this finger against those of Judea
Christian world view shows a prejudice
that is not in keeping with history why
is it people come to the shores of this
country okay I came here when I was 20
years old came through legally came
through though going through the hoops
came through answering questions because
we saw some ethical norms here and less
corruption in the political process than
from whence my brother and I were coming
he was 22 and I was 20 and the fact of
the matter is people don't realize it
was the bequest of that Sharia Christian
framework when China before this
particular one was quite demagogic
was starting to send their scholars over
to hear you talk to almost any Chinese
at that time you know what he would say
we were thinking of why is this country
so ethically driven and has the values
of human life contrary to mind when
Tocqueville came whom you mentioned to
What did he say that there were people
of faith we are now trying out that
which and engendered our values and now
we think we can have values without that
foundation yes the mistakes have been
made
but greater mistakes have been made by
those who denied the existence of God
every one of us believes in God every
one the only difference where they
believe in the real God or end up
defying ourselves okay now what about
the other perspectives
especially the pantheistic worldview one
famous Indian politician just recently
wrote in the Wall Street Journal that we
give freedom
whatever you want to believe and go on
and on well that's very noble if that is
the case but then we should revisit that
and talk about should we be making anti
conversion laws then if we make anybody
give people the freedom to believe why
then are we barricading anybody who
wants to choose otherwise so we have to
think these things through and so what I
say is we ought to give people the
freedom to believe or to disbelieve and
we do not what not to have a theocracy
because dictating religious belief is
the best way to kill that belief as
Europe finally evicted you know the
priest and the King as it were so I
believe you give the freedom to believe
in the biggest place we need to be given
this privilege is on in our academic
institutions
if universities would open their door to
intelligent dialogue with our
differences I believe things will change
it is the fact that they have blocked
out a prejudicial description of what
the judeo-christian worldview is all
about think of it this way and the
judeo-christian worldview is raining
yeah we had our views on sexuality but
we weren't sending people to jail or the
whole process now in relativism Hulse
way we are bringing everybody out of the
woodwork and what they did twenty thirty
forty years ago because we sought to see
them in jail it just goes to show you
that what you said earlier we all have
our absolutes when we bring them out
when it serves our own purposes it is
not the judeo-christian worldview that
is to blame it is the way some people
use their belief that I think engenders
this kind of prejudicial reaction so
given the fact that we do live in this
immensely prosperous time this immensely
free time you know the case that I make
and and continue to make is that these
are all outgrowths of a thirty five
hundred year process of history combined
with reason and that you end that this
is basically when you when you continue
to put pressure on a piece of coal
eventually you get a diamond and that is
that is effectively what has happened
with our civilization so why then are we
watching the rise of prosperity and over
the course the last couple centuries
alongside the rise of secularism across
the last couple of centuries well I
think you know
Anthony Cronin from Yale wrote that
excellent book called the end of
secularism and he was punning on the
word end meaning both its terminal point
and its purpose and he said that the
whole secular way of experiment was not
properly communicated in the whole
existence shall experience it wasn't
lived out properly and so it blew the
whole thing secular society is the
logical way to actually try to build
government but the freedom to give
dissenting voices their view is
essential if secularism is to be a
logical way of following otherwise if
you are anti-god anti-theists 'ok then
you have actually blocked the freedom to
express I think you're so well point out
what Locke had talked about you know
there the whole idea of how we are
endowed by our Creator with these rights
that's key is not given by government it
is given by God himself but what we need
is the freedom to discuss and interact
you know I've been the most common
question we are asked when we are on
campus and I have 90 fellow apologists
on our team we've covered the globe 12
13 14 year-olds come up to the
microphone and talk about the struggle
with suicide can somebody here tell me
what my life actually means why I should
keep from taking my life secularism
doesn't give you the answer because
secularism is born out of the idea of
Sekulow m-- just this early but of a
secular istic framework becomes to an NT
theistic framework then it's no longer a
legitimate secularism it is an anti
theistic framework of thinking and that
to my way of thinking is not what
secularism is all about we have to have
the absence of a theocracy but the
absence of a theocracy doesn't mean the
presence of an aunty theistic orosi of
whatever comes as place
America's a beautiful nation you're
right we're in the process of destroying
it we're blowing it big time
I came here at the age of 20 I'm 73 now
53 years later and I look at what's
happening if our children how to grow up
in a country of respect and civility I
believe we have to go back to the values
of the judeo-christian worldview which
give to us the sacredness of our origin
and the sacredness of our relationships
and the sacredness of my neighbor's
property and the sacredness of time from
everything of value that I am given by
God it's a gift the past is the past the
future we don't know the present is
rightly called the present because it's
a gift it's given to us right now this
is our moment to defend the world view
of the Scriptures and to do it wisely
and well O'Reilly that Christ is really
an honor for you to be here and I really
appreciate your time sir thank you so
much and Godspeed
god bless god bless your been so nice to
meet you thanks for the freedom
appreciated from episode six of the
sunday special one of our very first
guest was one of my favorites Michael
Shermer we'll get to his interview in
just a moment but first it is just a
simple fact that if you are not
protecting your data online companies
and bad actors are probably gonna go
after it I know most of you probably
thinking why you just use incognito mode
let me tell you something incognito mode
does not hide your activity it doesn't
matter what mode you use how many times
you clear that browsing history your ISP
can still see every single website
you've ever visited so if you downloaded
one of those cheap free VPNs online they
may be selling exactly the data you are
trying to hide it doesn't matter if you
get your internet from Verizon or
Comcast ISPs in the US can legally sell
your information to ad companies
expressvpn is an app that reroutes your
internet connection
through their secure servers so your ISP
cannot see the sites you visit
expressvpn also keeps all your
information secure by encrypting 100% of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available most of the time I
don't even realize I have expressvpn on
it runs seamlessly in the background of
my computer it is easy to use protect
your online activity today with the VPN
I trust and is rated number 1 by Cena
and wired visit my exclusive link
expressvpn comm slash Ben can get an
extra three months
free on a one-year package that's
expressvpn calm /ban exp ress VPN calm /
man expressvpn that calm / man to learn
more from episode 6 of the Sunday
special one of our very first guest was
one of my favorites Michael Shermer
Michael is a friend of mine he's also
founding publisher of skeptic magazine
that's a publication that examines in
questions the latest in scientific
thought he's the host of the science at
salon podcast and he's a monthly
columnist for Scientific American for
the last 20 years or so since his Sunday
special area is a brand new book giving
the devil his due
reflections of a scientific humanist
talks about free speech and politics
science and culture it's definitely
worth the read I definitely appreciate
Michael talking about judeo-christian
values with me as somebody who really
gets the importance of morality and
individual liberty but doesn't agree
that these things are rooted in Athens
and Sinai listen to us debate when and
how the perspective of the human
individual enters history and what
morality you can and can't achieve from
pure reason alone this is one of the
great puzzles of human history is number
one why this perspective on the human
individual only arose in the 17th
century if this is ingrained in human
beings that the individual is a value
and that we have to work with one
another then why only in a certain place
in a certain time did it arise it was it
a spontaneous combustion of human
thought and in the 17th and 18th
centuries or was this something that has
deeper roots I obviously would argue
this has deeper roots going all the way
back to Sinai and Athens but you how
would you argue on that yeah so I think
it's it's there's a tension there always
between the individual and the group and
then how do we get beyond the small
tribes tribal size of about 150 plus or
minus right who doesn't where everybody
knows each other or related to each
other so evolutionary sight can get us
all the way out to that now beyond that
we need politics economics culture
history and so on and so the one model I
use is I call this the in dugu effect so
in Jack Nicholson's movie about Schmitt
you know he's a retired insurance guy
and and he's late night watching and
there's one of these infomercials about
adopting a little kid in dugu in this
case and he gives money to a little in
dugu in the whole narrative plot is
around that he doesn't know in Dougal
from anybody but they show him the
picture of little indigo and here he is
with his soccer ball and his brother and
sister and here's their little Hut they
five dollars a day will give them so on
and now if you show a picture of ten
thousand starving kids in Kenya I'm not
giving any money or I'll give a dollar
whatever you show me little in dugu so
really that's kind of tricking our brain
into making little and dugu an honorary
member of our tribe my family my friend
I care about it because and that's our
evolved brain we care about people we
know or can identify with so to get
beyond that first of all you have to get
people to care about other people by
identifying them as individuals that are
like me so that sort of principle of
interchangeable perspectives that could
be me there but for the grace of your
case God there that could be me so okay
so and so how do we do that well beyond
getting people to truly care just having
a large society with the rule of laws
and and a democracy where we at least
feel like we have some say but more
importantly I think free trade is one of
these things where as long as you and I
are both profiting from some kind of
exchange we have I have no desire to
kill you and maybe I'll even start to
like you a little bit because you're
doing something for me so we know
government you know sort of liberal
democracies and free trade are these
things that provide trust in a society
among strangers such that I can go to
the Starbucks somebody waiting for me to
wait on me I don't know them they take
my money they trust me I trust them I
don't feel like I'm gonna get bonked on
the head or hopefully not arrested for
not paying and buying a Starbucks you
know that that the modern society is
based on this idea of trust among
strangers and that requires all these
extra add-ons so here I think of
economics and politics as tool social
technologies so my question still
remains okay I agree with a lot of your
analysis why the economics and politics
for a particular time in a particular
place is it accidental is that there no
we're just looking at a single sample
size and why is it that only in Western
Europe at a particular time at a
particular place in history do we get
this vision of individual rights that
flowers out and then starts encompassing
broader and broader groups of people
really again if this was embedded in
human capacity from the very beginning
then why does it only happen as the
outgrowth of one particular culture see
where I'm going
you know yep yep so well I think pker
tries to answer that and the good social
scientists that he is you know this is a
tangled web of correlations in in inter
causal variables that are going up and
down and it's it's really hard to answer
I mean you get a number of things going
on you know the Industrial Revolution
free trade is coming in you know double
entry bookkeeping and all these things
that kind of drive prosperity to go up
which which enhances a bunch of other
things so we can afford better
governance and so on then we have better
educational systems also literacy rates
start to go up everything any of this
has to do with it with the
judeo-christian system that is
undergirds oh well okay yeah so there is
yes that's part of it of course and so
just the Western idea that the
judeo-christian is you know sort of
founding helps push it along yes I know
we can go back to maybe the 13th century
or 14th century and you know the first
humanists in the 15th century long
before the Enlightenment yes okay so
there's strange grossest is talking
about human rights back in 1530 right
yes yes yes right so I think there's
multiple strands when you write a book
you got to start the right somewhere so
I didn't go all the way back to Athens
and Jerusalem you know like some people
do okay so there's some threads there
but the idea that the individual is what
counts and we're going to protect the
individual's rights you know like the
Bill of Rights for example is a perfect
example of my it's not the group it's
the individual in fact these rights are
there to protect you from being
considered a member of a group that we
feel we can discriminate no you can't do
that and that those have been expanding
that moral sphere has been expanding
more and more yeah no question and I
think this is where we all end up in the
same place it's really quite fascinating
again I've had conversations with you
know you and Sam Harris and we're coming
at it from a completely different angle
as far as the impact of God in all of
this Jonah Goldberg suggests that this
is the miracle and one of my great
objections to jonah goldberg it's
terminology and that is that I'm not
sure that the miracle happened in 1650 I
think the miracle happened a lot earlier
and the vet was the enzyme the catalyst
that led to this great outpouring of
human freedom but we end up in the same
place so the question becomes how do we
argue for that because we actually do
agree on a lot of these same values even
if we think the source of those values
is different right I thought the source
of those values begins much earlier I
think that it is embedded in certain
biblical principles that are that are
evaluated and reasoned through over time
but how do we espouse them so for me I
can espouse those values in in a
particular way starting from the premise
that there's a certain absolute morality
that was established by God this is
where the god question comes in and so
I'm wondering without that absolute
morality where how do we get to that
point where we can convince people I
just started reading Jonah's new book
the suicide of the web which is a weird
title because it's much much more of an
uplift at least the first half is very
uplifting right the mirror you didn't
get to the bads at the downside well but
his first page he says there's no God no
not in this book and I'm only gonna use
reason to argue for these principles
perfect and the reason that to me is
good not just because I'm an atheist but
that doesn't it shouldn't matter what
religion you are or in a sense it
doesn't really matter what the roots are
although it's intellectually interesting
whatever works if it works to increase
human flourishing of more people in more
places than I'm for it and and we should
champion those and make reasonable
arguments for why they're working and
full stop that's all we need to do so
where do you and I get our morals from
how do you know what's right or wrong I
tend to think we probably both get it
from the same place that is the still
small voice within
and then our culture our parents our
traditions and so on but where do those
come from and at some point you if you
go far back far enough you're gonna I
think argue there's a supernatural
intervention into the system it says
this is what's right or wrong but my
question would be how do you know
because we know from biblical scholars
that the Bible is something of a wiki
it's an edited volume we know people
wrote it down and he said well maybe God
inspired their writings or words or
something but if we just take something
like is killing wrong but we wouldn't
ask what is murder wrong and right
murder by definition is wrong but
killing is right well it depends and and
so how do you know and so this is as you
know Euthyphro dilemma that is you know
if these moral principles are out there
in some kind of you know Platonic space
floating around up there are they right
or wrong because God said so or are the
reasons and if we have reasons for why
it's right or what any God for right you
just skip the middleman and just go
straight for the reason so I actually
disagree with it I know I watched your
debate with interview slash debate with
Dennis Prager and on Dave Reubens show
specifically about this I'm not
somebody who disagrees that you can
Intuit that murder is wrong just without
without the presence of God in fact
Judaism basically says that Judaism
essentially says that there are certain
principles where if you were born in a
wilderness you would still be held
accountable for failing to abide by
those principles and those do include
murder right so murder is wrong whether
you believe in God whether you were born
in a barn it doesn't matter right there
are certain things you can Intuit but
some of the higher order morality that
we're talking about the value of
individuals or how far you extend the
tribe I'm not sure that that stuff can
be done simply through through pure
reason I'm skeptical of that
specifically because I think that what
we tend to do in the West is we tend to
say everything that was good was
enlightened been thinking and everything
that was bad was counter Enlightenment
thinking so this is my my criticism of
Steven Pinker's new book on the
enlightenment is that what Steven does
is he writes you know a 450 page book
about the enlightenment and never
mentions the French Revolution right he
writes at 450 page book about the
Enlightenment and he never recognizes
that Rousseau was a member of the
Enlightenment caste he was not even
Collins not encounter enlightenment that
the French Revolution was happening at
the same time as the American Revolution
essentially in the broad scheme of
things that there's a whole line of
thought including communism and Nazism
that considered itself over rational
very few actually if you actually look
back to the foundations of Marx Marx is
talking about imposing the reason of
humanity on the economic system and as a
whole so if your reason I'm not sure can
get you there is the argument that I'm
making yeah well okay first of the
French Revolution in the better angels
Steve talks about Burke and in Berkey
and conservativism and Burke was in
favor of the American Revolution against
the French Revolution why because in the
American Revolution you had a balance
between we want to overthrow the systems
that are not working but retain the ones
that are still good because those are
long hard-fought traditions that work
pretty well
now unfortunately slavery got thrown in
there but we eventually got rid of that
the French Revolution was like let's
just blow the whole thing up and start
over with including an under I remember
that but it was bit but they did
actually have a cult of reason right I
mean they actually their notre-dame
Cathedral and actually put an idol to
reason in the notre-dame Cathedral and
they had a cult of it so so I guess my
contention is that if you're going to
make the argument that it's self-evident
these principles eventually are
self-evident I don't think in the
absence of the the Burke
argument is in essence a religious
argument it's there is a bunch of stuff
that was passed down to us by our
forebears and we have the capacity
through reason to evaluate whether we
still think that the evidence is on the
side of particular rules or whether
these rules have been misapplied we have
to acknowledge the value of what has
been handed down as opposed to the
tabula rasa reason which might be
mandated by the almost by the social
science approach that is now being taken
up by a lot of folks people who might
have great discussions but whenever I
read Sam Harris's books and he says that
you know throw religion out the window
and we can come up with better than that
as I said to him when I was talking to
him well you grew up five miles from me
and we share a lot of the same
principles so I'm happy to have that
discussion with you but if you've grown
up in a society that had a different
tradition I have a feeling you'd be
arguing something very different and so
what I write okay so two things one I
think
pinger makes the point that most of
these are counter Enlightenment
romanticists traditions blood and soil
of the Nazis for example that it's it's
it's the you know the race that counts
and so on that now you may make rational
arguments about that and say I'm using
reason but your reasoning is wrong and
so we can we can we can say we're both
using reason and and this these
arguments are better than those
arguments so I think those are the two
points about that just anyone interrupts
it but I think that the question there
about the misuse of reason would be this
is that you are your pattern of
reasoning is wrong or that your premises
are wrong because your premises right so
if your pattern of reasoning is wrong
then we can all spot the flaw on the
reasoning a okay here's where you went
wrong or if the premises were wrong then
we're back into my argument which is
that the culture you inherit is a deeply
impactful thing on whether you believe
in individual rights in the first place
so I guess what I'm trying to get you to
yeah and maybe I'm trying to argue into
it is acknowledging that judeo-christian
values are at the very least utilitarian
even if you don't agree with the source
of them you agree that the the legacy
that begins you know with Judaism and
through Christianity in the Christian
world that is a that is a necessary not
a contingent part of history maybe but
how do you deal with then all the bad
side of the Christian tradition before
the Enlightenment right you know the
Inquisition the witch hunts so this is
the way that I deal with that is is what
I say is that the Bible was given to a
specific group of people if I were to
give you a written
right now I'd have to speak the language
that you and I were speaking I couldn't
use terminology that you didn't know I
couldn't give you rules that were so
deeply radical that they would run
counter to anything you could possibly
believe so for example when Maimonides
talks about sacrifices you know these
animal sacrifices that seem really
barbaric to us now what Maimonides is
arguing in the 12th century is see II
write about a document written
presumably by Jewish tradition 2,000
years earlier he's arguing that if
you're going to try and convince people
away from sacrifice you have to first
change the nature of the sacrifice you
can't just abolish something that people
think is completely dependent and and
necessary and then over the course of
time there are certain parts of the
Bible that speak to eternal human nature
right so for example this is what
Judaism Christianity would say is true
about sexual matters is that human
beings are the same regardless of where
they are they always have the same
sexual nature that is none changing but
what is changing is the necessity to
slaughter animals for example or what is
Nessa what is changing is the evidence
basis for witness testimony Yeah right
dude do you mean like when Jefferson
said all men are created equal but he
has slaves and but by today's standards
oh he's a racist but really he's just
trying to get something done and you
can't have everything so he's saying
look we have to use what we have now and
we could try to change that layer
essentially so to me it feels like
modern thinkers looking back at ancient
texts saying well when Jesus said this
in you know mark 327 he really meant
women should have the vote well Wow I
mean you're getting this out of that
passage you know it's a I think we're
reading back into it a lot of it I think
that you can you can find traditions
said to me that this principle of
interchangeable perspectives that is if
we're going to set up a society I can't
know which group I'm going to be in the
rauzein veil of ignorance and and and I
as an individual can't convince you to
treat me nice just because I'm me and
you're not me and and I have a
privileged position just because I mean
know so the golden rule is really that
and it's metallic derivatives as Pinker
calls them and I and I like that idea
because I think that is basic that
that's the basis of that is in this kind
of evolutionary model of my
selfish genes driving me to just want to
hoard all the resources but you're
making the same calculation so we have
to come kind of some agreement one way
to do that is for me to put myself in
your position how would I feel if I were
been and and I was doing this to him
well okay I would feel bad so I think
religions discovered certain eternal
truths about human nature
long before there was you know the
Enlightenment or or modern Western
culture at all I don't know how that you
know maybe by accident or just trial and
error at some point you're gonna figure
out maybe well okay well but by
observation I mean it's like that the
point jordan peterson makes about
novelists having deep insights into
human nature i think that's right and
there's a whole branch of evolutionary
psych that does evolutionary literature
like when shakespeare jane austen write
about their characters they're really
getting it right about how people behave
their sexual nature power structures
hierarchy the kinds of things that drive
conflict in human relationships they
figured it out long before there was
anything even called psychology how did
they do that by observing by paying
attention so I do think the religions
get it right a lot of the time just
because they're two thousand years of
four thousand years of observations that
get written down and then what we do is
go back and pick and choose the ones
that seem right and the other ones like
capital punishment for you know x y&z we
don't we don't practice that anymore
we've rejected those we accept these
based on what based on modern standards
like these are good arguments that will
use those and emphasize those to the
flock okay good I'm that's fine
finally I had the pleasure of speaking
to dr. William Lane Craig in our 50th
episode dr. Craig is a professor
philosopher theologian he's written over
30 books including the bestseller on
guard defending your faith with reason
and precision these books are really
fascinating really compelling
investigations of the conflicts and the
confluence between faith and reason
check out his books and also check out
his podcasts reasonable faith where he
covers apologetics like me dr. Craig
spends a lot of time speaking on college
campuses he also frequently debates
atheists on the existence of God so I've
actually read a lot of dr. William Lane
Craig 's work and
is a really interesting human being just
on a very personal level as a really
interesting story and really a creative
thinker sort of picks the apples off the
tree it's it's fascinating to talk with
them you can listen to us discuss how
Christianity seems to be losing its
place as a cultural influence in the
United States where this supposed gap
between reason and faith came from and
how to defend biblical thinking from
critics who say it's backwards we're
living in an increasingly secular age
where people by polling numbers secular
zarnow by polling numbers the largest
religious constituency in America why do
you think we're seeing such a decline in
religious belief in the West right now I
think what's happening is not so much
increasing secularization been as the
collapse of the old mainline Christian
denominations like the Episcopalians the
Catholics the Presbyterians the
Congregationalists and so forth and as a
result there is an increasing
polarization in American society people
are evacuating the middle and going
either to the secular end or to the
evangelical end evangelicals are
maintaining their percentage of the
American population keeping up with the
population growth but the impression of
increasing secularization exists because
the middle is emptying out and these old
line denominations are collapsing why do
you think they are collapsing in on
themselves and we're seeing it in
Judaism as well that the old
conservative Jews and reformed Jews
they're kind of dying away and you're
getting the modern orthodox movement
even moving toward more orthodoxy why do
you think that's happening right now
that's very interesting and I think it's
a reflection of the fact that people who
are just nominally religious in a sense
come to the realization that they don't
really believe this and so why should
you get up in the dark and the cold I'm
a Sunday morning to go worship somebody
you don't really think is there and so
as a result those who have been simply
nominal in their beliefs I think are
increasingly recognizing that in fact
they're secular and the unfortunate
byproduct of this is that Christianity
has lost its place of cultural influence
in the United States as this middle
mainline denominations empties out and
it's my hope that in coming decades
increasingly these evangelical
denominations which are holding fast to
biblical truth will begin to assume that
position of cultural influence that was
once held by the mainline denominations
well free to meet she declared the death
of God back in the late 19th century and
it took a while for that to become a
reality in the United States as far as
occupying any significant portion of the
public mind we're still significantly
more religious than Europe okay but
starting in the 1960s and moving beyond
there was a real move away from
religious belief generally what do you
think priests age that why do you think
that happened considering we we have a
civilization built on judeo-christian
values were incredibly prosperous
incredibly free and yet we seem to be
moving away from a lot of the religious
beliefs upon which our society is based
well I think in Europe and in Canada
it's the lingering shadow of the
Enlightenment that swept away the church
along with the monarchy because these
two were aligned and resulted in a deep
disaffection with Christianity which was
seen to be aligned with the old order in
the United States I think it's hard to
underestimate the influence of the
Vietnam War that war tore this culture
into and resulted I think in the
alienation of many many young people
from the values and the beliefs of their
elders and I suspect we're still living
with the results of that well there's
sort of a mainstream discomfort with
with religion that we see these days
religious believers are seen as sort of
anachronistic if you say that you
believe in the Bible or the God of the
Bible then you're seen as somewhat of a
fool these days
as somebody who speaks on college
campuses a lot and I speak in purely
secular forms about politics whenever I
asked about religion it's always phrased
in a sense of derision or condescension
why would you believe all that old stuff
well your work has been based on the
idea that faith is in fact backed by
reason you know that the presence of God
is a reasonable assumption to make about
the universe why do you think that first
of all there is that gap that occurred
that breach that occurred between reason
and faith is who were considered to be
mutual buttressing and supportive of one
another for centuries what what presage
that gap well I do think that this is
confined to certain disciplines at the
university particularly the soft
sciences and the social sciences those
who were disaffected by the Vietnam War
and the Cultural Revolution went into
anthropology sociology women's studies
literature religious studies and so
forth but in the hard sciences and in my
discipline philosophy I think frankly
there's a renaissance of theistic belief
and there is a virtual revolution going
on in anglo-american philosophy right
now where Christian philosophers
represent a significant and respected
voice in the philosophical community so
I find there's tremendous interest on
university campuses in these topics when
I debate a secularist on our university
campuses we will have hundreds and
sometimes thousands of students attend
these debates and the discussions are
always rational respectful deliberative
and so my experience is that there is
tremendous interest in our culture and
in the university age group in hearing a
rational fair discussion of issues
related to religious belief but one of
the things I think that's happened in
the religious community is you see
people who are brought up in religious
homes and they're taught the stories of
the Bible they're never taught any
deeper philosophy or theology that
attaches to that so they have sort of a
children's eyes view of what God is and
and how to how to think about God you
sort of think of gods
the old man in the sky who's controlling
things what if what in your opinion is
the most reasonable proof of God what
have you found to be the most convincing
proof of God's existence well I think
that those are two questions for me my
favorite argument for the existence of
God that I find the most compelling is a
version of the cosmological argument
which goes like this
whatever begins to exist has a cause
something can't just come into being for
nothing
secondly the universe began to exist I
think we have both good philosophical
arguments and scientific evidence for
the finitude of the past from which it
follows third therefore the universe has
a cause and when you do a conceptual
analysis of what it is to be a cause of
the universe you arrive at a being which
is an uncaused beginning less timeless
spaceless enormous ly powerful personal
creator of the universe so for me that
is a very convincing argument for God
but I find that with university students
that's not the most convincing argument
you can ignore philosophical arguments
for the finitude of the past or
scientific evidence for the beginning of
the universe but the argument that they
find i think the most compelling is what
i call the moral argument and it would
go like this one if God does not exist
then objective moral values and duties
do not exist that is to say in the
absence of God everything's becomes
socio-culturally relative to but
objective moral values and duties do
exist there are some moral absolutes
some objective values and duties 3
therefore God exists
now this is an argument which is
impossible I think to ignore because
every day you get up you answer by how
you treat other people whether you
regard them as having intrinsic moral
value or whether they are mere means to
be used for your ends and so this
argument I find tends to be the most
convincing
for people the other argument that is
brought up an enormous amount is the
supposed backwardness of the Bible
itself in biblical morality this happens
largely with regard to for example a
homosexual marriage it's been brought up
with regard to abortion which i think is
more again easily disposable to think
there's a solid secular argument in
favor of protection of human life but
homosexual marriage is the one that most
often comes up you also hear arguments
that the Bible permits slavery so if the
Bible is so wonderful then why are there
all these weird sections of the Bible
where it talks about wiping peoples from
the earth where it talks about where it
talks about enslaving other human beings
some things that we would certainly
consider moral evils today are
contemplated by the Bible and not banned
by the Bible so why why is that well let
me address briefly first this question
of slavery when we hear the word slavery
been we think of slavery as it existed
in the American South and as you know
that is nothing like the system that
existed in ancient Israel in ancient
Israel there was no social safety net
sponsored by the state there was no
poverty program so if a man got himself
into a situation where he couldn't pay
his debts he could keep his family
together and retain his self-respect by
selling himself as an indentured servant
to his creditor until he could work off
his debts and then he would have to be
set free after seven years he had to be
set free in any case so this was really
a form of indentured servant hood it
wasn't slavery as we think of that term
this was actually an anti-poverty
program and in some respects I think
it's better than what we have in modern
Western culture which destroys families
ruins people's self-respect because
they're not working whereas in ancient
Israel a man retained his self-respect
he worked for an income he paid his
debts he kept his family together and
that took all that slavery is just a
gross misrepresentation
now the
thing you mentioned I've forgot
homosexual marriage yes in citator with
respect to some of these other moral
questions I think we need to remember
the first premise of the moral argument
if there is no God then there are no
objective moral values and duties
everything is socio-culturally relative
so who's to say that the moral values of
a society that discriminates against
people and oppresses people is worse
than one which is liberal and tolerant
we just sort of assume that the liberal
values are the ones that would be
objective when in fact they're just as
relativistic as any of the other ones on
atheism so if we need God to be the
anchor point for objective moral values
and duties we cannot escape the question
when thinking of moral right and wrong
well what does God think of this
and if God prescribes something it seems
to me that's entirely within his right
if God were to say thou shalt not eat
beans or thou shalt not eat pork that
would be our moral duty and we should
obey it that is his prerogative as the
moral lawgiver and the supreme good and
so if God says my plan for human
sexuality is heterosexual marriage
that's his prerogative and there is no
basis for calling that I think into
question so let's talk about the
evolution of morality and I want to go
back to slavery for just a second so it
is true that that Hebrew enslavement the
Jewish enslavement of others is really
more indentured servitude and there's a
whole section in I believe it's it's
numbers or Leviticus insula Medicus
maybe where it speaks to specifically
about the slave who doesn't want to
leave and you're supposed to pierce his
ear on the doorpost as a punishment for
him not wanting to leave in all of us
but by the same token opus enslavement
of people who are not inside the the
Israelite inside the Jewish kind of
tradition that's not proscribed so the
idea of war cap
is obviously taken into account and not
banned so certain things are banned the
Bible certain things are not been now
the way that biblical believers have
practiced over time is that very early
in the church's history there are
already starting to eliminate slavery
although not for people who are captured
and then over time the West is the first
place to eliminate slavery altogether
specifically citing the sections of the
Bible to talk about human freedom and
the innate value of every human being so
is that an evolution of morality or is
that a realization of a fundamental
principle that was originally given to
people who couldn't necessarily
understand the full extent of the
principle I think I think it's the
latter and I love the way you put it I
think that's nicely put
Jesus said something very much like this
with respect to Old Testament
regulations on divorce they asked him
whether or not it was lawful to divorce
a woman for any reason and Jesus said
Moses allowed you to write a certificate
of divorce but it was not so from the
beginning and he cites then the creation
story of Genesis of Adam and Eve and
said what God has put together in lot
let not man put asunder
so what Jesus was saying there was that
the law of Moses was a temporary
prescription accommodating the hardness
of heart of the people at the time but
it didn't represent the perfect will of
God for human marriage which was
grounded in the creation story so how
exactly do we determine when we have
moved beyond the biblical text in terms
of the evolution of that morality when
are we fulfilling a broader goal that
was that you know was kind of held back
by temporary constraints and when are we
moving
utterly beyond it and again here I'm
thinking of same-sex marriage so when it
comes to same-sex marriage the argument
is now being made by people in liberal
churches including including people to
judge who's running for president that
basically Jesus was seeking equal
respect for everyone he cared about the
least of these and the prescriptions on
homosexuality were really more in
homosexual activity were not eternal
precepts but were really attempting to
crack down on
the promiscuity of the time or they were
temporary expedience
yeah all right I think that's clearly
false when you look at these regulations
both in the Old Testament and then
they're repeated in the New Testament in
the strongest terms in Romans chapter 1
there's no doubt that Paul is thinking
of this as a moral law that has abiding
significance and it's grounded again I
think in the creation story that God has
created human sexualities created man
and woman in such a way that the
fulfillment of that relationship will
take place within the safety and
security of a heterosexual marriage and
that outside of that sexual activity is
not to be indulged in and this is a law
that God has given us for our good so I
do not think that this is capable of
simply being relativized to time and
culture so when you argue with students
when you talk with students and discuss
with them what do you find is the best
way to approach them when it comes to
the precepts of traditional
judeo-christian morality do you come at
it from the natural law perspective or
do you come at it from the biblical
perspective I guess I share with them
the moral argument that I shared earlier
in our interview this moral argument is
very powerful with students because on
the one hand they've been taught
relativism they are scared to death of
imposing their values on someone else
so it seems right to them that if God
does not exist that objective moral
values don't exist they think their
subjective person dependent and relative
but then secondly the premise also seems
true to them that objective moral values
do exist they think it's objectively
wrong to impose your moral values on
someone else and the values of tolerance
open-mindedness and love have been
deeply ingrained to them and so they
believe both of the premises but have
just never connect
the dots to see what logically follows
from it and this can lead to some
bizarre conversations I remember with
one fellow when we would talk about
premise 1 he would agree with it and
deny two so when we talk about premise 2
he'd agree with that and then deny one
and so we went back and forth back and
forth with this poor fellow flailing to
try to escape the logical conclusions of
what he himself believed so I find
approaching it through this moral
argument as the best way one of the
things that's been fascinating to watch
is people broadly accepting the efficacy
of the precepts of religion without
accepting the underlying truth of
religion so here I would point to my
friend Jordan Peterson who talks a lot
about the practices of basically what
our religious practices the idea make
your room do the moral thing duty but he
doesn't talk in specifically religious
terms he speaks in union terms he talks
about the idea of deeper precepts that
are embedded in myth which is really
embedded in the human psyche he doesn't
make the the kind of truth of religion
argument he instead makes the if you
want to get ahead you're gonna have to
do this stuff argument for wanna be
happy you're gonna have to do this stuff
argument and that has tremendous
cultural appeal do you think that that
is beneficial do you think that that is
enough where how far do you think that
goes I think it's beneficial but it's
not enough when I had a dialogue in
Toronto last year with Jordan Peterson
rather than attack his position what I
tried to do is to be Invitational and
say look you and I both affirm the
objectivity of moral values and meaning
in life I want to offer you something I
want to offer you a grounding for those
values that we both hold dear because
for him as you say been there just sort
of floating in the air they don't have
any metaphysical ground in his worldview
so he's got the right values and and and
meaning by and large but he has no basis
for them and I'm still hopeful that he
will come to embrace God as an objective
metaphysical reality who will provide a
basis for those values and meaning in
life
thanks for joining us this week gang in
our discussion about judeo-christian
values leave us a note in the comments
and let us know which topics you'd like
to see us cover in our future reviews of
these Sunday's specials
we always appreciate you listening
thanks so much for joining us
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
produced by Mathis Glover
executive producer Jeremy boring
associate producer Katie Swinton our
guests are booked by Kaitlyn Maynard
post-production is supervised by Alex
Singaram editing is by Jim nickel audio
is mixed by Mike McCurry no hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva title graphics
are by Cynthia Angulo the Ben Shapiro
shows Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyrights daily wire 20/20